alright hey everyone today we have a
door Chun she's a YC partner and
co-founder of home joy thank you
how's it going good how are you good
alright we're gonna do some office hour
questions from the internet so let's go
cool
so first question is from Topher
Peterson and he asks how many users do
you have when you applied to YC and also
how much revenue had you generated so
when we apply to YC back in 2010 we were
a company called a time path joy joy and
we were a marketplace for online
services so we're trying to bring on
typically offline services like tutoring
life coaching therapy and all these
legal services online and our thesis was
this was the time to put it to video and
and we would be the ones to do it
mhm and so when we applied if I remember
correctly we had on boarded a lot of
people for the supply side of stuff so
service providers but had on-boarded
absolutely no one yet on the demand side
so we had obviously generated no revenue
yet but that's what we had only okay
and this was 2010 2010 okay and had you
started a company before no I had
previously worked at a company called
slide and we and I ran product there and
we built Facebook apps the developed in
2007 one the Facebook platform jet just
launched okay and what made you want to
start a startup I think I've always knew
that I wanted to create stuff yeah
except for the world and it just was a
matter of finding the right idea okay
and so after a couple years at slide I
decided it was the right timing also
because my brother who would be my
co-founder yeah I just graduated college
and I said hey you should just come out
here let's work on stuff so we started
working on stuff did you did you have
any like I don't know apprehension about
starting a company with your brother not
really I think it's funny because my
brother and I grew up kind of in
separate worlds so it's not like we were
together all the time or you each
other's if we were compatible working
together so it was a little bit trial
and error in the beginning but having a
sibling working with
you know you can trust them and they're
not gonna do anything horrible to you
yeah and so I think there was just that
initial layer of trust that was okay
pretty good for us yeah and also I guess
you were out here for only a couple
years you didn't totally have a network
either exactly right yep yeah makes
sense
cool all right next question hotly asks
how do you keep going if you can't raise
any money so you just have to keep your
personal burn really low and I would say
this from experience where my brother
and I weren't able to raise much money
for two and a half almost three years
and we were just able to just keep going
in terms of trying to find users and
stuff like that you just got to be
incredibly scrappy because obviously you
can't afford to acquire any users so
which means which is actually a good
thing because it forces you to get out
of your chair and you have to go talk to
users guess the only way that you can
get them to use your product and I think
that's I think going through a period of
not having enough cash to work on your
startup it gives helps you develop a
lean mentality which is good to keep in
court if you if and when you raise money
mmm-hmm had you raised before YC no we
had it okay and then you raise like a
hundred yeah we raised a hundred K
around demo day yeah and then use that
for the next two and a half years hmm
that's kind of that's amazing yes it was
your own place just the two of you it
was just the two of us we yeah was just
two of us Wow
yeah okay cool it was cheap to live in
Mountain View at that point so it wasn't
really well cheap relative around that
time it was about 900 bucks a month for
like a one-day one-bath he took the
white how much was YC money at the time
it was I believe we got 15k so each year
total total total okay and then we
raised 100k from someone else and you
made that last for two years 12 years
yeah Wow
just didn't do much besides work on us
yeah there there's another question
that's like further down the list but
somewhat related to you know keeping
going or quitting
so Alejandro repartee asks how or when
you decide to walk away from something
that you started so that's a tough
question I think when you I'm assuming
he means the startup or an idea that
you're bidding on I think this was one
of the things you actually have to think
about before you start which is okay
great this is an idea maybe you got some
users so and so forth before we even
even think about raising money or heart
especially hiring people we you should
really think about is this something you
want to do for the next five six seven
ten years because success is way down
the road and I think if you can't
imagine yourself doing that then that's
not something you should jump into
mm-hmm
but if it is then certainly you should
go for it and then I think during a
journey your startup journey if you ever
start questioning yourself of am I am I
you know am I in the right game or not
then yeah I think it's important to
always zoom out and reevaluate but I
wouldn't be doing it in the corner by
yourself I would always find a set of
friends in the startup world but also
outside the startup world to give you
some of that perspective and if that
doesn't help you know you can always
find it a coach to help you talk through
that and and then if you do have if you
have raised money or you have employees
you do have responsibilities to them or
to your investors as well as to your
employees which is not to say keep going
because of that but it's just to say you
need to find a transitionary role or
period in which you take care of all
those duties did you struggle with that
at home Jay no I think we no not not in
particular I think I just kept on going
I think there are times we were like are
we working on the right idea or not
Aaron and I my brother who's my
co-founder we pivoted a dozen times
before we got to home joy and so which
was helpful we pivot the fact that we
pivoted that much it was helpful in the
sense that we were we learned how to
push product out very very fast
which was helpful when we finally got to
the right idea but certainly every when
you're when each time you pivot you sort
of just think and maybe maybe two more
weeks maybe there's one more feature
maybe you know maybe if I just got one
more user and things will take off and
so you just have to step back and always
reevaluate that how do you pivot twelve
because like where you ended up from the
initial application isn't that far did
you like it yeah yeah yeah so we started
with marketplace for online services and
it was just marketplace for an offline
service right
starting with cleaning and then
eventually some other home services yeah
I don't I I don't know if I'm not sure
if that pathway could have been
shortened or not okay I do think we
learned a lot along the way in terms of
working with touch other that really
helped us to make that take off at the
time that we came to it do you remember
what you did in between like was there
anything that was just like objectively
crazy um there were a lot of terrible
things I mean I think we also built at
least I built over engineer a lot of
things because I thought it was cool to
build and stuff so after I'm not gonna
remember all of them but passed away it
was a was trying to connect service
providers with clients when that didn't
start working out when we couldn't find
enough clients for the service providers
we had all these service providers so we
started we're like what can we do with
all these survivors well they still need
a clients and we thought okay what if
they just we just made it into Q&A site
so we had a queue a night save Q&A site
for a while after a while I think a lot
of the search providers got tired of
just creating freaked essentially free
content how they weren't getting paid
okay yeah they weren't getting paid for
it it was I mean sort of kind of the
pitch was if you write all this content
then it'll help you develop your brand
right yeah marketing and then it rolled
into a bunch of content sites and then
and then it turned into basically like a
demand media type play and
we weren't just I think by the time you
rolled into that were just like this is
not going to be huge and we're not
really into this so um let's just
rethink the whole thing yeah
Oh to go back to your other ideas
you said you applied with like at which
type ideas well right no yes so on my
application I just reread it I applied
with the marketplace for online services
but there's a question on there which
says your other ideas and my other idea
literally is twich which is not to say
that I made a mistake to not build it
because I'm not quite sure I would have
made that huge thing yeah it's just that
it was just kind of funny for me to see
that you literally just brought like
video game streaming no it was just
watching people play games and checking
in and commenting and doing all these
things kind of like ESPN for games
essentially and the reason how it came
off idea was because I was always
watching my brother play games and he
would also then go on youtube and watch
other people play games and I'm just
like that's so weird to me but he was
doing in like a bunch of other people
were doing I was like okay there's
something here yeah and but the thing is
I think I'm not really into games that
much and so I'm not quite sure that of
I'm pretty so confident when I worked
out right yeah it may have been a little
early as well at that point yet life
streaming was yeah yeah cool all right
let's go to the next question
Chris Melnick McDonald asks what advice
and lessons did you learn in entering
the Canadian market so with the Canadian
market just like any other international
market there were the custom from the
customer perspective there wasn't that
much of a difference on everyone you
know you have a dirty home and you need
to get it cleaned yeah so and so forth
from the cleaning professional side the
service Burroughs so that writer side
there is there are some differences
there in terms of you know where do you
or do people find jobs in the US its
Craigslist and other places in other
markets it's something else so there are
there are those kind of differences that
we had to learn about mmm but I wouldn't
say they were a super major so there is
how to acquire service providers there
are maybe unique channels to acquire
customer
in each one of the local markets there
was things just like weather traffic
like where are the traffic jams public
transit how are people actually go in
and go from house to house and that hot
to be all baked into the scheduling
stuff so anyway going back to the
Canadian point it's not that there was
nothing super special about Canada
itself it's just it's just the fact that
it's another market that we went into
mmm and then we also launched in in the
Europe as well Berlin Paris and London
and similar to that there are there are
some locale differences and obviously
language differences as well yeah but
nothing super major so yeah what are
your pro tips then like if I'm expanding
- I think candidates like very close to
the US I'm expanding to Europe
what are your pro tips um for that is
I'd go I'd go to the mark and identify
the opportunity first go talk to
potential users for us we're a
marketplace so it had to be both sides
yeah the users and there were some
markets where we looked at and I don't
can't recall exactly the right cities
but that we decided just not to enter
because we didn't think there was enough
demand or supply there for us for us to
make an impact but once you do that then
the other thing is if you're launching a
one of these cities is to find somebody
who's hopefully done this before and we
call them what we call them was the city
launcher and so this person would go
into the market find the first few
customer or sorry I find the first few
service providers first we clean
cleaning professionals and then we would
match them with the customers and kind
of there was kind of like a manual
back-and-forth going on to get the
supply and demand running and then they
would find and then if it worked out
then we would find a city manager we
would hire full-time city manager to run
the operations and be in charge of the
PNL there and I think sort of that
playbook that's been played out now and
so a lot of startups have I think
execute on this well so I think that's a
pretty good framework okay okay cool so
another question related to kind of like
getting started when when you're small
yah-ha alum Ronnie asks
how do I work on culture or do I even
work on culture in the very early stage
when I'm just building a team in a
problem so the number one thing about
working on a start-up is finding the
right co-founders and finding the root
front-running your co-founder is pretty
much setting the culture because it is
how you work with that person is going
to parlay into probably how you work
with other people so I don't think it's
like you need a handbook in like right
out your core values and all these
things right away I think it's much more
important to know if your startup is
going to survive or not so how do you
get your users how am I going to make my
first book I do think once you start
hiring your first few employees then
that is an important time to try to
figure out try to articulate that things
so that one you're hiring the right
people but two there are some people
coming in yeah have some expectation of
how things are going to be run how did
you guys figure it out because there's
like there's so much unspoken with
siblings yes determine what that's part
of the company culture and what's just
like you guys that's a good question we
wrote out or core values at some point
we had five or six of them and that's
the way we that's the framework rito-san
which a lot of companies choose I think
but in the beginning both of us would
interview everybody and then we would
actively talk about it like is this the
right person would they work with us
well and so on and so forth and then go
from there okay so kind of just like
seeing if the person is a good fit
rather than like explicitly writing all
the valleys down yeah early days it
really days yes we eventually wrote all
that values down but I think in the
beginning we were just looking for smart
people who were going to work hard who
wanted to help cleaning professionals
get work yeah
and or into the mission of the company
okay cool
so another homejoy question Adam Sanders
asks what was the best decision you made
for homejoy
so I think starting the company
obviously I don't regret at all we were
able to bring
a great crew of people to work together
and so what I am most happy about in
most paths and was most passionate about
was the fact that we created a platform
that created work for people who needed
the work as well as did a service for
people who were busy and you know having
a clean home is one of those things that
it's hard to say it's not articulate why
but when you have a clean home you're
just happier and you're more relaxed and
so after a busy day of work it's nice to
be able to go home and just not have to
clean it so I think those two thinks so
starting that company I'm proud of that
and yeah like I said I think our team
was a great group of people who really
cared and I would take nothing back to
for that yeah cool next question
huija wall chaunt Jehan asks would love
to know what's the one thing she you
would do differently in hindsight if you
were to start over again and I think
that's like home joy and life context
yes so Ruth okay so with home joy there
are so many things that I could have
done a lot better but if I had to
aggregate a lot of them into kind of
like one concept like a bucket yeah a
bucket it would be I would had
prioritized I would have prioritized you
need economics much earlier in our and
in the in our company so by that I mean
when when you're building a marketplace
you're always in this constant battle of
trying to figure out how to allocate
resources between growth user experience
and unique anomic s-- and so what we did
was we obviously we heavily worked on
all three of those things
but if you had to make me stack rank
those three user experience and growth
came before you know economics
so this makes sense if and only really
if there is one ample funding available
and what I would think three other
things so one is there are strong
Network effects they're really strong
network effects or two there are strong
economies of scale mm-hmm or three
there is a clear first mover advantage
so one of those enable funding or a
combination of those last three that I
said mmm-hmm no strong rocker fix
economies of scale and first mover
advantage but in a case in the cleaning
space it turns out that there are some
of those there but not to the extent of
uber or Airbnb yeah and which meant that
we did have an opportunity in hindsight
to have a much slower growth model and
still maybe came out at top not you know
winning in the long term and so like I
said in hindsight had i known about had
a foreseen what the dynamics of funding
dynamics would have been when we needed
to raise money i would have certainly
made the decision to at least equalize
and put equal effort into you know those
three things growths user experience and
economics if not had prioritized that
and what's even higher when you're when
you're advising YC companies do you kind
of have a rule of thumb I mean every
company's different but say there was a
company similar to homejoy
yes saying like you should be operating
at like a whatever like X percent margin
to be in a good spot finding a
particular there's no constant margin
you should be at it it's really
dependent on the local market I think in
the prices you can actually bear but I
do emphasize uni economics and use your
experience above growth I think unless
in some very odd scenario which there
are very few that like I said there are
really strong Network effects and that I
think you can potentially raise a lot of
money
yeah to just drive through some
not-so-great in economics but in general
I don't think that's really the case
yeah those are usually the catastrophic
failures
yes all right next question
Nikita butakov asks what are some unique
data science and machine learning
challenges you faced at home Troy
so I think some of the cool things we
worked on well there are a lot of things
but maybe I'll list three top three
first did they come to my mind one is we
had to create a lot of prediction models
for demand so that we knew how to how
much supply - on board so that supplying
demand weren't out of whack um they're
always almost always out of equilibrium
out of whack but you don't want it to be
too too much imbalanced another one we
worked on is we did a lot of analysis on
customers and finding out which kind of
customers were the best for us in terms
of lifetime value and so we figured out
things like we should be targeting
targeting pet owners for example they
were like 2 to 3 X more valuable than
regular all things evil than regular
customers okay and then finally one of
the more difficult challenges was
scheduling when you have thousands and
thousands of cleaning a day and you have
references on both sides of the market
place as well as things like transit
transit issues and you don't want people
traveling too far from one house to
another and so and so forth that was a
difficult challenge resolved next
question alejandro repair t asks from
tim ferriss how has a failure or
apparent failure set you up for a later
success I hope people mostly take Keller
2 as a learning experience and not to
let it get you down but but you should
be should be honest with y'all yourself
and know what you learned from it and so
I mean today I advise I help a lot of
startups and so I think
the previous things that didn't work out
for me it it provides a really strong
foundation in a basis of how I can help
people but I always caveat that every
time I help somebody I always think okay
what is a situation they're in
it never is going to be a copy and paste
from my experiences and so I I always
think about that first and foremost and
and that's what I told most people when
they get advice from people especially
if they're going around to way too many
people is that like you're you're your
own situation and you and and people
will give you potentially directionally
correct advice but that's just
directionally in the right direction
right like like I said it's not a
complete one-to-one mapping yeah and so
you always should be taking that into
account yeah it's difficult and it
messes with your confidence if you take
advice from too many people yeah
especially when they're from all over
the market like if I was starting a home
joy type company now and I talk to you
yeah I think I would take your advice
yeah but just some random other startup
founders like why yeah you know yeah I
know you must talk to so many founders
that yeah sorry uh coming with patterns
in your head I mean that's like kind of
the YC thing too right it's like just
pattern matching yeah
and unfortunately so many of the like
pieces of advice just sound trite after
a while yes because it's tweetable but
in reality it's kind of like all about
the nuance behind the scenes right yeah
so yeah I mean you can tell like culture
is important or whatever go talk to
users there's so many ways to say that
stop burning money so fast
yeah there's yeah and so all of these
things are just like at the end of the
day like you have to build the thing
yourself and you have to have some
confidence because like taste matters a
lot in your company in your product and
if you don't have your own opinion like
I don't know how you're gonna go through
it yes I agree which is yeah I mean
obviously you develop that but over time
you're like you're trying out 12 13
different products before around into it
actually I did I did want to go back
because this was about like so something
of failure for a later success I wanted
to talk about you doing your PhD yes
well because I think it's also
interesting to people yeah would you
regard that as a failure I would regard
that not as a failure but as time
sometimes I wish I had that time to get
back yeah and I could have been working
on creating things instead of you know
creating I don't know economic models
and being a data monkey and you know
trying to do simulations and stuff like
that on my all my fancy yeah fancy very
academic models and so but but yeah I
spent right after I graduated from
undergrad I you know I actually got a
degree in computer science and didn't I
come from South Carolina and there for
the reason you know that your choices
are a little limited in terms of what
you're exposed to so I was never exposed
to Silicon Valley was never exposed to
tech startups or any any of these things
so you know by the time I was like 20 I
just didn't even know that existed yet
mm-hmm
and so the thing I decided to do because
I didn't want to work at a big company
as a code monkey was to go get a PhD in
economics which sounds weird but I was I
was doing some engineering work for an
econ professor and so I fell deeply in
love with the idea of becoming an econ
professor yeah like I think it could be
fun but I generate a lot more meaning in
value doing what I'm doing today
yeah value definitely meaning I don't
know people like make their own meaning
yeah for me personally that I am no
qualms with people who decide to become
econ professors right yeah totally
question not unless side projects are
you building side projects right now to
like keep that product building I don't
know gene muscle working yeah I started
working I I start well this is one of
the things because I'm not working a
startup I start a lot of things I see
something cool and they just like start
working on it and then but so one on
this thing I'm trying to adapt right now
yeah on aetherium and just playing
around the solidity and all these things
we're starting to invest in a lot of the
crypto blockchain startups now and so I
think it's really important that I truly
understand how this stuff is built so
I'm doing that and nothing else major
besides that but I'm always I always
like tinkering around with something
it's always tough like I've had the same
itch and I I desperately only want to
complete things I hate letting things
like die on the vine
yes but it's hard because yeah I'm
equally curious yes just run I go back
away for a weekend and like see what
happens yes well what's the last thing
you thought something out this week that
was like auto transcribing podcast oh
that's right news yeah yeah which
speaking of unit economics I might be
like committing the mortal sin of
selling a dollar for 80 cents because
you still have a human doing it yeah
acting like the little stuff yeah got it
so I have to figure out like either
full-time employees or Mechanical Turk
which I've never gotten good results
from at scale actually like it a scale a
little bit larger than what we're at
right now I could have someone full-time
like fixing podcasts yeah but right now
it's a lot of like Craig waking up at
5:00 in the morning and being like do
something because I'm doing it have I
created my own $5 an hour job so dumb
okay raise prices yeah you can always
raise prices yeah I think that's a fear
that I personally like have but should
be okay with breaking yeah because I
didn't yeah I knew that if I started too
high I wouldn't get enough customers
fortunately it didn't give away any free
demos if I gave away free demos and
because we hit one on a Chen and if we
were doing free demos it would have been
a disaster yeah this is this is a very
actually classical error not to pounce
on you or anything oh no I mean I did it
myself at home joy too which is to get
the first few users in door people tend
to want a discount and then what you
haven't done yet but
is that you continue discounting and
then all of a sudden you have a stream
of just the worst kind of users because
the people that come in just because of
the discount are super value driven so
they want the cheapest thing and they
want the ten star service for what you
can only provide at maximum as a five
star experience and they always drive
the most customer service costs and it's
just a big headache so it's good it's
maybe okay to get the first few in
because I mean what they're hopefully
also giving you in return is a lot of
feedback and improving on the experience
and stuff like that but at some point
you definitely don't wanna be skilling
that definitely not ya know I mean it's
only like a couple a handful right now
so it's like totally fine but I mean I
just honestly didn't know if people
wanted it in that so I was like this
would be a easy way to find out
it turns out they do yeah and it's a lot
of work yes podcasting is getting really
popular it's crazy and the need to edit
a lot of them is pretty high too ya know
we were doing the not to make this a
craig podcast but uh we were doing the
text-based audio editor for a while and
i found that i was using it a little bit
and i was using the other ones like d
script and and there are some
competitors but i'm still so much more
proficient in premiere but at the end of
the day I still wanted transcripts yes I
was like this is a product I want yes
and yeah turns out so they did is it's a
transcripts and then you can also edit
it basically we've killed that man
killed editing yeah because it's really
interesting on the technical side but
yeah like I said like it wasn't the
product that I needed anymore got it
which is I'm a little rare because I do
video as well okay but yeah it's a lot
more helpful like when you put it on the
blog that there is a transcript there as
well to follow and look back on and
probably search through as well I
imagine yeah so it's kind of it's
multifaceted so it's like SEO for sure
sharing because we can generate little
quotes and stuff some people only read
podcasts yes which is like as personally
as like an affront but that's fine are
you a 2x listener no really I've done
for but as I used to do it and then I
realized I was talking faster yes
because we've talked about this before
but like you and I would like be at home
all day and not talk to someone I had a
moment where I was like I've only
listened to podcasts of a coffee shop
talking to the poor like the folks that
like to XP
yeah there's if you listen if all you do
all day is just listen to things at 2x
and then you go talk to somebody you
always wonders like why are you talking
so slow they're talking normal speed but
it's like you are talking unbearably
slow right now so yeah yeah I've
actually met a couple podcasters in
person after I was listening to them at
2x speed I was like oh my god you're so
slow and then you get really used to
listening to podcasters so you know it
like Joe Rogan I've heard so many of his
episodes that I'm basically like no the
anecdote that's coming up yeah it's um
like skips skips but anyway yeah
podcasting is awesome
TBD how much money there is and yes cuz
it's all like content marketing or a lot
of content marketing right now yes yeah
I agree
yeah cool all right next question
cm Mac F I'm not going to pronounce that
last name asks what are the best
practices when reaching out cold to an
investor really easy keep it short
say what you want to say if you can do
in two or three sentences and then ask a
specific question which is can we get
knock which is not can we get coffee
which is actually something that they
can answer and actually help you with
yeah
and that's not to say that that investor
would never meet with you it's just you
have to remember these investors are
getting lots of these emails and they're
also yeah you like their job is to take
meetings from people that are entering
them so all these warm intros and so you
just need to figure out a way to develop
a relationship with that person and one
way is just to have a back and forth
over email over time yeah then when it
becomes interesting enough basically
when I get to the point where I'm
writing three or four paragraphs back
I'm like okay never mind Lister get on
the phone or meet in person because this
has now gotten to the point where I'd
like to actually talk to you for a long
bit yeah and also investors hang
on the same sites that hackers hang out
on and like product people hang out on
so if you're out there making stuff you
can get attention oh yeah oh yeah reddit
AK news all these places yeah they're
all there like they hang out on product
on it's like you don't have to just like
pretend the only email it's a way to get
their attention yes because this is like
one of those things that's like you you
make up these like little excuses for
yourself where ad origin twerp on in my
email it's never gonna work out and like
that's just cheating right I agree all
right next question from named with a
bunch of emoji in it I think it says
Riley Soros they're a they asked is uber
Forex still a thing people would invest
in in the US so I definitely think so I
mean we've seen the scooter craze going
on now I think that when I think about
uber Forex I think it's push a button
and a bunch of logistical ly hard
operational things happen in the back
and then you get a product at service
like within a few seconds few minutes
within a day or something like that and
that to me shouts convenience and I
think a lot of people want convenience
that's something people want
yeah and so I think there's always
products and services to be built in the
uber Forex realm yeah and I think that
yes there's definitely less overall less
money being put into it than say four to
five years ago but and that's a result
of investors understanding and learning
about what these business and models
look like the fact that their most of
these businesses grow a little bit
slower so that you can build up a great
user experience and understand they
understand that you need you got you
know economics much better as well yeah
and so there's I would say not as much
hype but there certainly if you're
growing and you have good retention and
good engagement you certainly can
probably get funded has there been a
large success that was kind of like a
follow-on company in this way like work
kind of like a copycat or just like a
derivative example I'm trying to I mean
you know like well so using the uber
Forex example then you just like oh
we're gonna you know
this thing cuz it's just like uber oh I
mean when uber came out there are a lot
of these like uber for cookies and he's
like I know there are a million failures
I've been yeah we're looking for success
yeah I mean there I wouldn't group all
this into kind of the sharing economy
stuff yeah well so if you look at
mobility there's cars bikes scooters now
yoikes mmm-hmm outside of that let's see
there's yeah that's a good question
for some reason nothing jumps in my mind
I'm sure it exists but I think it's just
not like a dominant player like
something massive yeah I don't I can't
think of anything
massive except for let's see that's if
we go to Asia and China all the food
delivery stuff is rocking and rolling
there seem here actually I mean there's
a tandoor - so I think that's working
well there's some storage companies that
may do well yeah yeah there's no nothing
- though I mean if we try to compare it
to uber I think it's gonna be very hard
right but actually I'm yeah I'm so wrong
cuz like Google wasn't the first search
engine so it's definitely not about
being yes yes so yeah all right next
question is a phaidor Paretsky they
asked has ycs views or have ycs views
changed on cryptocurrency blockchain
related startups since coinbase and
their coin basis YC company right so has
it changed
I think we've we've learned a lot more
just because there's more activity in
this yes I think every partner probably
has a different viewpoint of it for me
personally I'm super excited about
what's going on I think in general
people should be general should be
excited when a lot of smart people are
working on something diligently and I
think there's there's a lot of
tools and stuff like that still to be
built for this to take off but if I try
to like game out how far this could go I
just think the possibilities are
limitless so the thing that really
excited the stuff that excites me are
when you look at countries cities or
countries in which there are bad
currencies
or just bad financial infrastructure I
think these are obvious places where
blockchain in crypto can help a lot and
move them forward if not even leapfrog
maybe other countries and then there's
other and then similarly in the in those
countries usually there's also issues
with like property rights and stuff like
that so I've talked to folks in Greece
and places in South America where the
concept of who owns land like each piece
of land is almost non-existent it's
somewhere in a drawer maybe in pencil
and paper but even then who knows if
that's real and so I think if any of
these countries or cities are serious
about it they could leapfrog you know
centralized services and just put it
onto the blockchain and wouldn't it be
cool if you do that not only I well one
is just identifying who owns property
like that would drive I think economic
growth in itself because it wouldn't
send advise people to actually do stuff
but on top of that is increasing the
more transactions that can happen so
even in America trying to buy property
or exchange property is extremely hard
it's extremely expensive and it seemed
it seems to be unnecessarily so and so
anyway I think likely in registries is
an example of something I'm would be
super excited about to see happen is
that the DAP you're building no I don't
build inverse in oh is it just like
building a blog sending myself fake
tokens I mean it's on the yeah it's but
the the thing that comes to mind for me
with crypto and blockchain is I think
there's a lot of skepticism because of
what's being built right now but
actually think that what's being built
now is are the right things being built
in the sense that one there it's such a
new technology that there are still so
many issues potential security issues
and putting the wrong types of smart
contracts on there and and so now you
see a slew of consultants and also
companies doing security audits and
we've just invested in a couple
companies they're building AI to help
ensure better security and ensure that
the economies don't go out of whack and
stuff like that and so I think doing
playful things and building playful apps
is actually the right way to help
develop the ecosystem because you don't
want i think super serious things on
there without all of this stuff being
built already right one of the things
that we talked about earlier was i think
it's super for this to go anywhere as
well we need ux people and product
people right now it is just way too hard
for somebody to use these stuff you know
do you know what the DEA use for adapts
are sorry yes I'm guessing it's really
small yeah ten thousand Wow okay that
was pretty good I don't know the exact
number now but the last time I read it
was like around I just know like how
much of a pain in the ass meta mask is
yes install it and then you got a you
know move money to it and and all this
stuff so yeah I think that needs to be
solved before this goes mainstream and I
thing is all these things are solvable
yeah it just needs to be built and with
due time it will be built and we're more
than happy to help accelerate this by
investing in startups who are building
this stuff and the other thing is also I
think more of a pure and branding thing
I just think the word blockchain has
been thrown around so many times that
people don't fully understand what it
means for sure and so there's a bit of
an education I sort of think that when
it goes mainstream we don't need to use
the word blockchain per se just like we
don't use the word database to explain
Facebook ya know like my parents don't
know what Ajax is yeah it's not
important yes exactly just need to tell
them what it does yeah yeah it's it's
ultimately it's the product yes but I
think with like with so many smart
people working on it it seems highly
unlikely that something won't come out
of it yeah that's so cool
probably related to that question Manavi
asks what type of companies is YC seeing
more of for this batch we've seen a lot
more applications on the crypto
blockchain front
so super excited about that we continue
to see more more applications on AI
machine particular machine learning and
deep learning in the applications for it
across so many fields now
and so that's excited I don't think
we've seen anything where we've seen
complete automation yet of anything
really
but it's kind of cool that we're
building tools and stuff like that to
help doctors people in the field doing
work and stuff like that and what else
are we seeing biotech seeing lots of
those which is exciting particularly the
intersection of software and biology and
then also we just launched our YC bio
program which is which all the companies
go through the three-month program that
that all the other startups go through
but it's targeted towards people or
companies that are still in the lab
research phase and so the and so we're
and we're focused on what's on the sub
area right now which is health span and
longevity and so we've seen a lot of
those and we're really excited about
that do you have a strong opinion on how
long you think you're gonna live I don't
know I hope for a long time I would like
to live over a hundred I guess okay or
whatever the current life expenses
expectancy is which is lower than 978
yes like that
I mean I try to do all the things to
make sure I'm healthy and sane but I've
you know
I don't I don't do any drugs or anything
- yeah I self go know caloric
restriction oh so I mean I've tried
doing that and I didn't notice any
specific change other than like a little
bit of weight loss yeah
but I actually go back and forth on that
a little bit
I'm trying it out oh really so so I do
the whole like I've done in three six
month spans the whole 18 yeah don't eat
for 18 hours and and actually like the
first week it looked kind of hard it's
just like probably any diet you go on
it's like the first week it's kind of
hard but it's actually pretty simple and
I haven't done the whole fast for like
48 hours thing though have you yeah yeah
that's fine like you you feel better
fine get used to it I mean the first
like by the end of the first day you
really are starting to get hungry and
then you push through it and then you
could go like another day or two and be
totally fine mm-hmm
I mean but also my body fat isn't like
1% right so maybe if I was like that
skinny yeah it would be different yeah
but yeah I'm similar to you like I've
tried everything out I know when I do
the intermittent fasting or whatever I
can be leaner yes
but the selling point is that you you're
gonna live longer
it was just like hard to feel a
difference and like ultimately with all
this stuff I'm I'm just kind of like man
you gotta live yeah I want to hang out
with my friends and like have a beard
granted yeah so I also want to make it
200 I don't know we'll see we got some
time yeah I want to make it pretty far
and still have an active mind I think
that it's probably most important for
most people is just I'm having an active
mind still yeah yeah it seems like the
further we can push the quality of life
happier we're gonna be overall because
it's not really about like yeah a lot of
people lose it well before 78 right so
cool all right next question
yah-ha LM Ronnie asks what are the best
marketing strategies for a year one b2c
startup so the best ones are always the
unpaid ones
I think I mean this is almost a cop-out
but if you build a product that people
love they're going to talk about it and
that's the best way to grow
I think tactically speaking there are
other things you can do content
marketing which you're an expert in so
you can talk more about that and there
are other tactical things if you're if
you're a consumer product and there if
you won't come into your website and no
one's signing up or anything you know
one of the things that this seems like
counterintuitive advice but is to just
put a phone number on there hmm
and people still want to call people
still like to talk to people surprised i
installed the drift or intercom yes
product until last year people use it
all the time yeah I mean it should be
obvious because it's like successful
company yes they use it all the time
yep yeah so having a chat on they're
putting a number on there it's a it's
actually a good thing because if no
one's signing up at least you can talk
to these people and figure out what it
is that they want or what's going wrong
so finding just easy ways for people
with contact use also another way mhm
yeah yeah I mean I would did over the
content marketing I would say don't
waste your time if you're not gonna make
something good mmm
because it is really easy to get on the
the content marketing treadmill and be
like oh man we just gotta like bang out
this stuff put something out every week
and and if you look at like the
analytics on YC content it's like a
power-law with like the the stuff that
gets the most attention is definitely
not linear and and even just the things
I'm sure with you as well like the
things you work on yeah what like people
talk to you about you're like dude I did
that article in like two days
okay thirty years later you're talking
to me about the ones with the least
amount of effort you get the most views
it's crazy I don't know yeah I mean
maybe you should just write like silly
pithy tweets
do list still work well because one of
the top posts is that essential advice
oh yeah that that works well the I mean
we couldn't replicate that essential YC
advice post because that was an
aggregation of you post over time people
like list people like book lists mmm but
do you also want to think like why are
the people even reading it like we can
with with a lot of our content we could
get more attention by interviewing like
YouTube celebrities but to what end
yeah I was talking to someone who
watches the channel and they were like
oh that's cool like I like all your like
science and tech videos like what's Y
Combinator and so you if you're like not
getting them all the way through the
door it's yeah especially when you're
tiny and like you don't have a full time
person making stuff yes yeah I would
just figure out like what actually works
for you it might focus on doing a good
job of it rather than just mailing it in
sure because that that stuff is I've
never had luck with yeah do you think
that it's articles that work best I
guess maybe it's depending on the
product or do you think podcast videos
like what form what medium works yes I
think people still undervalue the
ability to write clearly there aren't
that many people that can write well so
if you can get someone who can write
well specifically in a niche and then
get a channel to engage with it like
hn:m hmm you can get a ton of traffic
because people can consume the entirety
for the most part consume the entirety
of the content whereas with the podcast
like you have to be like hardcore like
podcaster or youtuber youtuber works
pretty well are YouTube works pretty
well when we cut it up into Clips right
but if you look at the retention like
it's like anything like there's a huge
amount of drop-off right whereas with
the article so it's easier to do right
but I found like I don't always have a
great thing to write
mm-hmm and the podcast is a much easier
way to like keep consistent or they're
not to make this into a podcast about
content marketing to me
intriguing are there like blogs or like
what companies do you feel like you do
content marketing really well mm-hmm I
would break it apart into different like
categories mhmmm actually I think like
not to uh you know blow ycs like I'm
trumpet but I think PG did a great job I
think like YC is actually like one of
the best content marketing companies
ever except they would never say that
but like hn + PG essays are content
marketing sure i think on the companies
i think like a 37 signal Basecamp does a
really good job
those guys have like established
themselves as like thought leaders but
also make content that's pretty relevant
and they're they're gutsy enough to have
an opinion mm-hmm whereas a lot of
people aren't sure strong opinions
matter and probably get more views yeah
especially when it's contrarian right so
they're like they exist in the software
space but they've like pushed pretty
hard to be kind of independent yeah in a
similar way like indie hackers did quite
well for that so I think that like that
stripe acquisition made a lot of sense
because people connect to Cortland sure
I think intercom has done a really good
job but I mean honestly like I pay
attention to a lot of people on YouTube
because I think like for the most part
like Silicon Valley still doesn't
understand how big it is okay like just
the amount of like pure traffic and
consumption it's a rabbit hole it's
insane I found myself watching some
weird videos after two or three hours
there's like one after the next step to
the next step Phoenix and you're like so
we did a podcast with them Casey and I
stabbed mmm and like he gets more views
a week than almost any TV show and
you're just like what this guy like
rides a boosted board around and then
you find out that he's like representing
a significant percentage of boosted
sales mm just this one dude in New York
and you know he's super talented and
that's like a lifetime of work I get a
ton of creative energy
but it works really well like if you can
find someone like that so yeah and I
think also but then like on the SEO side
like I think nerd wallet has done a
great job all right like they have all
those like best credit card type things
and it's not like spammy yeah so yeah we
did a whole content marketing podcast
actually oh yeah first roundin
andreessen horowitz oh cool yeah so
we're like oh that's right all right
next question
yah-ha alum Ronnie asks what would you
say to a founder from a third world
country where there is a big lack in
tech talents and you can't compete with
big corporations due to a lack of
resources in terms of hiring so the way
to always get around this is to seem
more exciting than these big
corporations and one way is if you're
technical is you just build the product
yourself and start getting users and
when you start growing and you start
getting revenue you can probably go
poach these people I always think that
in a big company there's always like a
fellow entrepreneur in there somewhere
stuck somewhere and another but if
you're not if you're not technical it's
a little bit harder but there are enough
sass tools out there these days were
like Weebly and all these things where
you can just patch together I think
something and get something out there
and iterate a bit to the point where you
can also get users yeah and in revenue
and I even see today like engineers like
real engineers they're sort of
embarrassed to do it but they have to do
it and they'll just like put up a
Shopify site first yeah they totally
hate it because they're like I can do
this much better if I customize it
myself but in reality like that's how
you're gonna get your first few users
quickly who's doing that and so once you
do that then again you can go through
the same cycle of trying to go find
people to join you yeah with something
that looks exciting yeah I mean I would
encourage people with with like sales
aptitudes to get people to pay them
because if you're good at sales you're
probably good at convincing people to
think that your product is good before
it exists yeah and only once they give
you money do you know yes they really
want it yes I've made that mistake
before all right
aspiring angel asks what's the best way
for investors interested in startup
seeder angel funding to get started and
how does location affect that process so
I think these days it's really easy to
get started I think one place you can go
is we have a sort of investor school
that we held a few weeks back that one
of the partners here Jeff Ralston did an
amazing program with it it's all in
YouTube and it's on YouTube yeah and so
I would watch all of those a couple
times and then another thing to do is
there are like we said earlier there's a
lot of all my communities where people
are making things and so it's just start
hanging out there and talking to
founders and seeing how they think and
more importantly if not most importantly
is using the products mm-hmm
and figuring out you know developing
hypotheses on is this gonna get big how
could this get big you know work at this
go and then finally just contacting the
founders I think founders especially
when they're starting off no one's
really talking to them that much I think
if you reach out to them I think some of
them some percentage of them will be
more than happy to start talking to you
yeah what about when you you start
talking to a founder and say you're even
talking to a YC founder and you feel
like the price is high mm-hmm I would
say is if your start if you're doing
early stage investing price should not
be really an issue because in venture
business
it's the exit that counts and I don't
and you shouldn't be investing I think
in a company that you don't think it's
actually gonna do well to whatever
standard it is like it doesn't have to
be a billion dollars but you know to
whatever standard you want it to be and
honestly like at the end the day
valuation is supply and demand and
that is what drives some of those
evaluations and so sometimes you just
the pay up to get involved yeah yeah all
right last question so adora you've been
at YC now for two and a half years
roughly
how has your view of startups in the
world in general changed since then so
despite all the horrible stories in the
news I have actually become much more
optimistic about life in the world and
startups in general I think you know we
are at work I see we're sitting in a
pretty privileged position of you know
to spend a lot of our time thinking
about problems talking with founders
here trying to solve these problems and
then seeing all these new cool
technologies that they're creating
that's I certainly couldn't do myself
and so I think when I think about if
just some of these people do well like
the world can change yeah for the better
and so yeah so I'm just optimistic I
guess more optimistic what were yourself
I'm in complete agreement I mean I think
that's like it's too easy if you read
the news to believe that everything is
black and white
and yeah there are I didn't quite
realize it until I was at YC that like
people want to treat Silicon Valley
broadly and YC specifically is kind of
like the Yankees and so it's sort of it
sort of doesn't matter what you do
they're always gonna be like haters up
there but seeing people come in like
specifically when they're just like
they're there building you know like
like artificial wombs and like all this
crazy stuff that's going to be the
future and it's super exciting so yeah I
mean my personal strategy is to just
like not pay attention to stuff yeah and
like talk to people or building things
yeah you know what is really is somewhat
indicative of this is the scooters I
like when I got want to fell in love
with it and I just really yeah I just
like this this could change mobility
within us
not just scooters but bikes and you
remember these other a navy and stuff
like that but then what's the one it
started taking off people just started
making fun of it right
what is this San Francisco thing and
like ruining everything and everyone
looks like dorks riding them but then
but then then those the critics I think
started some of them anyway
I think riding these scooters and
they're like oh it's actually like I can
see I can see why this could be a thing
and so just by using it and being part
of it and so I think there are some of
these barriers maybe a week that are
that are dropping well I think a lot of
companies and products have done a bad
job at making people feel included yes I
think that people react strongly when
they feel like they don't have any
agency and so you know it's ironically
right like people will be tweeting
something about how terrible something
and Silicon Valley is and how people are
terrible and then you meet the people
here and they're just like I don't know
I just like want to make something cool
yeah so there's this very weird divide
yes that that's kind of just in people's
heads yes and I think in this in age
it's everyone's responsibility
yeah to know at least try to predict the
reaction of anything you put out there
yeah because you know the world is the
world is you know at where it is now for
better or worse yeah and so it's just
been great thoughtful what you put out
there's it's actually important yeah
totally I mean yeah overwhelmingly
positive and I think technology is much
bigger than a little app on your phone
yes keeping that in mind I think it
keeps you excited yes yes cool all right
well thanks so much for making time
thank you so much have fun
you